[Música]
os homens aos insetos bons e atendendo
todos os aspectos
quem é ver que deslumbrou olhar e
perceber nesses seis anos incompletos a
completa aprovação do mesmo trecho de um
poema de john boy é do século passado em
que ele consegue traduzir muito bem o
que eu tenho que tentar
nessa vida profissional e mostrar pra
comentar questões ambientais na linha
cascavel porque ela não pode fazer parte
da tarde e durante a noite os pisos e
com isso manter 25% das florestas
tropicais animais são muitas vezes
ignoradas na interpretação da natureza
porque quando a gente vê um besouro
estranha tanta gente que gosta de pisar
em fazer greve
e aí na minha infância eu nunca tive a
infelicidade de passar por uma
experiência de aprendizado
não é aqui você espera de um lar em
apresentar uma lista de animais úteis
quais serem a vaca nos dá o povo que nos
dá cá como a visão toda voltada
[Música]
justamente o que aconteceu
imaginando de vista à copa
a barata campeão não tem que falar do
ferido nesses animais
é preciso que se contassem necessário
contar a história inteira porque quando
a gente começa a ser discriminada
nós estaremos discriminando as pessoas
que todos somos parte da natureza e eu
como médico de terminar esse ano
completa 40 anos de forma que este tempo
todo o meu trabalho seja no zoológico ou
agora arrancar as que a nova função
biológica
quando a gente passa a receber também
animais para a recuperação e esses
animais são desenvolvidos na natureza
que inventar essa gente esquece
nós então a oportunidade é descobrir em
cada serviço de s
o encantamento o olhar desses animais
para nós conta justamente com a malvada
quebrado macho havia quebrado esse olhar
que o meu filho o que você vai fazer com
o pico é grande a roça responsável
e têm acesso à educação por que tanto
medo tanto recessão terá terminado
e aí a gente quer mais importante dessa
vida e é isso que faz com que nós
acreditamos leves
é isso que faz com que a gente coloque a
natureza finas como cenários onde o ser
humano faz parte
e aí quando a gente não se sente parte
desses ambientes
a gente não luta pra quem tem coragem de
dizer que esse é um do mau olhado
ele é mineiro ele é o lobo guará é
solitário
tive mais que tenha um papel na cadeia
alimentar também peçam a guerra velha
[Música]
então cada vez que a gente trabalhar
pela forma cada animal e gera em nós
temos outro exemplo também de aulas que
são desejadas que são praticados e que o
nosso cotidiano a cada momento chegam a
vossa animais humanizados que passaram
por traumas foram retirados dos livros a
entrada de dólares que precisam ser mas
a gente pode esquecer da beleza esse
serviço
essa companhia respeitosa cenas que
foram colocadas no planeta para que a
gente tenha uma praça com ele a gente
não pode perder essa oportunidade
ontem todos e todas as nossas
experiências de pensar ver que nós
fazemos parte do mesmo sangue e por isso
mesmo estou sempre preocupado os meus
trabalhos em criar projetos de educação
ambiental e projetos fossem levados
atuando a população não sempre acreditei
na educação ambiental de massas
democrático que todos pudessem
participar devido à urgência das
questões ambientais
a gente vê hoje tantas ameaças
mesmo assim eu tenho um olhar otimista
sobre a questão ambiental sempre tido
qualquer conhecimento muito mais não fez
do que o trajeto é lógico que a gente
não tem o direito de falar uma criança
[Música]
quem somos nós pra eles são obrigados
que tem esse lado não encontrei uma vez
uma criança em 1985 quando eu estava
começando
os projetos de educação ambiental com
grandes parceiros da prefeitura de
partilha da oxfam
pessoas que começaram com medo e aí
encontrei uma criança e ela era do bem
rigorosa e essa criança e deu o primeiro
toque que o primeiro ensinamento
eu sempre nós passamos o dia inteiro
juntos com um grupo pequeno de crianças
e essa criança chegou pra mim e no final
do dia um dia estafante que é
considerado só é usado o tempo de aula
e aos de deficiência
ela pegou pra mim falou o seguinte
professor mas para o senhor porque é
natural que é meme
e aí eu fiquei sem resposta porque até
então eu achava que estava sendo
extremamente didático naquele momento
passei o dia todo falando na toma da
flora brasileira e essa criança bem com
essa pergunta mas é uma professora que
chamou a atenção não é observa as mãos
dessa criança
aí eu pedi problemas essa mão as mãos
estavam a caminho mas o que aconteceu o
sarrafo essa mãozinha toda machucada
aí me disseram que essa criança já pesou
o quintal do desenho daí as mãos
machucadas por que você pediu que viesse
de calça comprida conheço e nem o carro
teria de estimação mas à parte
e aí eu comecei a perceber que a
educação ambiental a questão ambiental
não é somente isso
apesar de toda uma pessoal só flores que
é uma questão de saúde e outra criança
em 1986 também de outra opção e eu
comecei a fazer para as próximas
partidas uma delas um desses eventos no
bairro horto no final do dia já é ser um
bilhete de uma outra criança
eu não tive o prazer de conhecer ela
deixou um recado pra mim no papel ou um
pedacinho de papel escrito assim
obrigado por vocês terem se lembrado de
nós e é esse foi 'morrendo' dessa
certeza deveria sempre pensei preciso
ampliar o tratamento que eu tenho pelos
mesmos
é preciso criar oportunidades para
aquelas pessoas que nunca só uma parte
não conhece um parto natural uma reserva
natural com a gente nos ao longe que tem
uma conotação ambiental não é somente
pela internet pelo contrário só
permanecem em cativeiro
quero ver aqueles animais soltos e aí
que eu disse pra todas as pessoas que
convivem
convive com o antigo maior espetáculo da
terra
a gente observa o serviço tome criaturas
divinas está aqui para nos ensinar ó e
este entendido eo pior muitos deles
acabam com ó a nossa responsabilidade
com as gerações e depois nós e quando eu
fui o maior espetáculo da terra
o reto aos temas que a gente central
todos nós presidentes da casa não temos
absolutamente os animais não podem ser
discriminados tantas mas até agora as
mulheres menstruadas que passa em cima
da copa rocca
a obra de notícias bichos e pessoas
a eu juro que eu vi uma mulher e acorda
amor ela colocou cacau na ponta do pé
[Música]
dela
são três discos que vão sendo criados
agora tem todo o aspecto que ó mas que
vão fascinado geração em geração e que
fazem crescer mais ainda houve
incompreensão
ao determinar o sucesso é tanto que uma
senhora chegou perto de risco geológico
quando você olha não tem coração mas com
ronan apressar a queda de algumas
escolas que tenham a mesma eficácia que
isso no fio
se querem matar eu tenho pressão alta
eu tenho hipertensão foi mais um motivo
pra senhora conhece o que é do veneno da
jararaca senhora faz toma o remédio é
assim mesmo acontecendo na vida esse
animal ea cada momento nosso trabalho só
oportunidade que eu não posso fechado
compartilhar com vocês
a macaca do zoológico
ela vai virar uma ilha para os filhotes
filhote e começou a bater nas costas
porque não consegui agarrar as costas
dela
na verdade o amor e ela tentar de todas
as formas
porque essa é a condição de todos os
primatas do neto na li na é preciso
pular mas vamos retirar o que dá um
sofrimento para a macaca também que os
animais têm sentimentos trabalho e
[Música]
quando foi pegar o filhote a mãe ficou
furiosa
daí então deixa pra lá
no dia seguinte de manhã estava lá do
lugar onde é tabu
o g20 tem a uma ilha onde se tem o local
e se for o alimento estava confiante ea
mãe esperando quieta título agora tudo
isso eu digo pra lembrar que a gente não
é tão diferente nem da espanha
vamos apenas nossas mãos de observar
vamos comparar por exemplo com a água
que você aperta
olha o nosso dinheiro polegar
olha o tempo dedicado ming wen grandes
mas que essas fotografias nos mostram
uma coisa que a gente não pode perder
assim
nós temos no mesmo nosso movimento aqui
é do mesmo modelo e é isso que faz com
que a gente não perca a nossa referência
porque é muito 3 passar por um mundo sem
ter a oportunidade de entrada beleza à
nossa disposição entre as que têm cada
vez mais acho que aparece nesses 40 anos
de profissão eu tenho orgulho em dizer
que todo o meu trabalho foi de cavaco
tem sido dedicado à divulgação da
educação mensal
a divulgação das questões
mentais para todas as idades a todas as
pessoas
eu não posso falar classes sociais mais
de dois milhões e 500 mil pessoas já
passaram pelo evento e eu e uma grande
equipa que me acompanha sempre buscamos
fazer e quando eu ouço então
interessante então não há informação
cada vez mais à frente eu lembro
exatamente dessa pessoa que ainda está
deficiente visual durante uma copa que
ela tocasse uma forma que eu viro
inocentemente para além de um mero e
meio é a medida dessas boy ela pelo
caminho só segurando meu filho sentidos
presta atenção
e aí quando eu falo de caminhos para o
tratamento são é oscar rosa é essa
passagem é que nós iremos aprender a
preservar o planeta
a sensibilidade todas as formas de vida
e aí quando eu vejo
imagine o seguinte um dia vão dizer que
a validade da apple mesmo quando ela
tiver o mesmo olhar de admiração de
desdobramento de uma cobra coral já foi
lançado no dia que a humanidade deve
demorar
diz uma pessoa gerando certa qualquer
servir o seu copo direito
não cabe a nós com tv direitos momento
para outras pessoas
quanto mais saúde aí sim a humanidade
está em vigor e é isso que eu pedi
essa é uma luta
esse é o meu trabalho também
[Aplausos]